Andrew here we are man yang speaks
tapping speaks I speak if the truth and
you hear it you know what's funny so
we've been going through various
conversations and a lot of them have
been more like yang listens because when
I have a guest I just want to hear them
talk and I'm not an [ __ ] so you know
if you have a guest in a podcast you're
not like that's what you think well
here's what I think that's not like not
that cool so you know it's this is what
I'm struggling with I'm like we can't
have yang speaks if yang doesn't speak
very very zen
I suppose I guess so that's what we're
trying to do and we're gonna we've a lot
to talk about a lot of things we want to
dive into I think what we're going to
try and do is explore how we can do
these episodes in a number of ways and I
think a good way to do them in angel now
talking's that lets get Andrews
perspective on the topic of the episode
and then working the speakers as we go
so today we're basically talking about
current events and what's happening with
you post campaign coronavirus universal
basic income and where the world is
going which is a lot it's an awful lot
and I have to say I haven't been off the
channel for that long and we suspended
in February and then there was like a
wind down period and then we setup
humanity forward as quickly as we could
we got it up I want to say maybe three
weeks after we suspended so and that was
a lot of work and I'm really glad
because now humanity forward is doing
work trying to help us through this
coronavirus crisis and if we didn't have
this organization set up I'm not sure
quite how we would be
operating so we've distributed 1.3
million dollars to various struggling
Americans most of whom were in the Bronx
cuz the first big thing we did was like
a big slug of money to the Bronx but now
we've been giving money to folks through
humanity forward in micro grants of
originally 250 to 500 dollars and then
we shifted to a range of between 20 and
500 dollars because it turns out if you
get 20 bucks it's really uplifting
you're like oh that's nice and we
thought that we could help more people
that way a little bit faster or a lot
faster because we've been overwhelmed
with demand and the need it's a very
very hard time so I'm thrilled that we
were able to transition immediately into
helping we just placed our first PPE
order to help the city of Detroit
because I've been advising various
people on how we can how not we but how
they can put resources to work most
effectively and so we identified that
there are certain geographies that you
could save lives in by getting PPE to
them because they don't have enough and
their cases are starting to shoot up so
I'm glad that we're doing what we can to
help and there's just so much work I
mean I said to someone yesterday that
like I feel like I wake up and I bail
water all day and then I go to sleep
honestly but but but the fact that I
feel like I'm bailing water all day is
actually an outgrowth of the fact that I
feel like I'm one of the few people in
our country who might be able to help
right now despite the fact that most of
us are trapped in our houses so I'm
doing all I can and I'm super grateful
to everyone who's donated to humanity
forward that's allowed us to help and
you should know that beyond the
coronavirus relief fund we're working on
other things that I think can help move
us forward and then there's the entire
big picture well what are we gonna do to
rebuild our country after this crisis
starts to abate because the damage is
going to be far and wide
and we're going to need to think much
much bigger about how we move forward if
we're going to start putting people in
position to succeed and flourish which
is gonna be a lot harder after millions
of jobs get blasted to smithereens which
is what's happening right now and most
of those jobs or if not most many some
significant proportion of those jobs
will not return that's clear and anyone
who talks about this like it's gonna be
a rubber band snapping back does not
understand how organizations or the
economy or human nature work so we
started this like food perspective it
takes a step back we pound the pavement
Iowa for 17 days in a row there's more
than that and then we hit New Hampshire
we drop out of the race and instead of
resting we're like we got to get an
organization up and we started this
thing thinking hey we should do some
like long term like double-blind studies
on universal basic income give millions
away and track you know just prove to
America how much this works we set up
the organization I went to Mexico man I
was like I'm taking a vacation would be
great well raise some money and we'll
give these we got plenty of time to give
the money away and I was in Mexico and
the next thing you know the president
United States talk about universal basic
income direct cash payments to people
around the country because of
coronavirus so I don't know if you well
you think Andrew I feel like the best
thing we did was set something up even
though the part of the mission has
changed and essentially because we're
now a relief fund in a lot of ways but
it seems like having that entity helped
us at least get to action even faster
than we thought even though I didn't
really get a vacation yeah I'm thrilled
that we're able to help people right now
and that it's not us trying to even you
know get email addresses or whatever the
heck you know or whatever like the bait
the basic things are that we had some
resources that we could put to work and
to me if you have the ability to help
right now you have to help there's just
no choice and so I'm grateful that we
enough of a starting point where we
could immediately commit a million
dollars and then raise more and start
helping bail people out a lot of people
I was very touching that they say that
we were the first to help because most
people haven't gotten their stimulus
checks as of this conversation right so
we ran and you talked on the trail all
the time about the impact of the fourth
Industrial Revolution and automation
devastating the American economy and now
you're looking at what seems like a lot
of these trends accelerating I think you
said another conversation that we're
looking at like ten years of damage in
the past month or two like what what are
you seeing in terms of stuff you had
talked about now being accelerated yeah
I said ten years of change in ten weeks
which is what what this is going to end
up being so you know though all those
brick-and-mortar malls and stores that
were on the edge a lot of them are gonna
close Macy's just furloughed the
majority or all or nearly all of their
130,000 employees how many of those
stores are gonna reopen at full strength
and when I mean a lot of those people
are never going to come back to work
and you can multiply that times all of
the other retailers all of the
restaurants all the bars I mean some of
them will reopen when the time comes
clearly but some of them won't and there
are many small businesses that are in
the same boat
you had the vast majority of Americans
living on the precipice before the
crisis and then if you just turn off
everyone's income for a period of weeks
or months then all of the fragile
businesses die and the strongest
businesses just get stronger Amazon just
set an all-time high their stock price
as of today this conversation think they
they're hiring about 75,000 people so if
you were to see the Amazon efficacious
of the economy that has been ongoing
where a third of America stores and
malls we're going to close over the next
four years they're gonna close right now
essentially or they're closed right now
and they're never going to reopen you
have many many companies
that are figuring out how they can do
more with less how they can shrink their
workforces how they can have everyone
work remotely ongoing so they don't have
to pay for real estate how to automate a
lot of that processes and I have a
friend who advises major company CEOs
who said that all of the CEOs are
telling them we're going to shrink as a
result of this we're not going to bring
back a lot of people we're gonna
automate processes this is going to
speed up the progress of the fourth
Industrial Revolution where more and
more companies realize that people are
often just a drag on their numbers
really and one of the big misconceptions
out there is that somehow when you
invest in a company on the stock market
you're investing in job growth you're
investing in profit growth if there's a
company that can do more and become more
profitable with fewer employees then
that's the way the company's gonna go
the job loss yes
it's gonna accelerate terrifying but one
things you talk about is the human cost
of that so I'd love your thoughts like
what do you you talked a lot about
mental health on the trail you talked a
lot about social stabilities and
families like does that accelerate too
now all of it accelerates unfortunately
and so we the trends that I was
concerned about in my book are now all
the more pressing and prevalent and
certainly the automation of jobs is
number one and the need for universal
basic income but the the declining
marriage rate and fertility rate mental
health crisis and the mental health
crisis going to explode through this
time our use of the crisis text line
which is a service or if you are
considering doing yourself harm has more
than doubled during the crisis which
makes sense because we're all anxious
and depressed and a lot of us don't know
what the future is going to hold or even
where our next paycheck is going to come
from so the trends that I was most
concerned about are deepening
or speeding up it's going to be really
really difficult to reverse many of them
without some
of marshal plans scale reinvestment in
our way of life that looks different
than previous plans and the first step
in that plan in my mind needs to be a
universal basic income where you put
resources into our hands and then allow
us to rebuild communities from the
ground up from our people up our
families up build this trickle up
economy I think big public works are
gonna be a part of it infrastructure is
gonna be a part of it making our society
more environmentally sustainable in big
ways will be a part of it but a lot of
it has to start with re-centering our
economy around ourselves our people our
families rather than imagining that
what's good for these mega corpse is
going to somehow trickle down on us I
okay so for those of you I'm gonna
assume I know there's a lot of people
who were familiar with your campaign
listening in for those of you yanking us
here we love you for those you're not
you mind just quickly high-level Andrew
tell us what what you mean when you say
universal basic income or ubi for short
the universal basic income is a policy
where every member of a society gets an
amount of money to meet your basic needs
no questions asked
and during my campaign I was running on
a freedom dividend of $1,000 a month for
every American adults during at age 18
and that may sound familiar because now
we're all getting 1,200 thanks to the
stimulus checks so this plan is not my
plan in the sense that Martin Luther
King was for a version of it Thomas
Payne was for a version of it Richard
Nixon Elon Musk lately a lot of people
that have come out for it over the years
Barack Obama said at some point that
we'd have to consider it and I don't
want to put words in his mouth but like
when I talked to Brock about this he
said that what really hit him was during
the recovery from the financial crisis
where a lot of companies weren't
employing people the way they used to
it's like you sort of rebid these
companies and then they don't hire
everyone back and so that really had a
big impact on him we're gonna see the
same thing now it's like these companies
are gonna rebuild and they're not gonna
employ people so a universal basic
income is an idea that's been with us
for a long time and the central idea is
simply to put money into people's hands
so that they can meet their basic needs
every single month and now I will say
that my thinking has shifted where I
believe that the freedom dividend of
$1,000 a month might not be sufficient
like I think that we should have that as
a starting point but I'd now be open to
more because the problems are just so
much more pronounced in terms of
people's ability to supplement that
income I imagined that $1,000 a month on
top of your gig or temp job could work
but at this point your gig and temp job
is gonna disappear we need to get health
care for everyone we need to put money
into people's hands and then we need to
rethink how people get both money in
their hands but also how people find
structure purpose and fulfillment beyond
9:00 to 5:00 that frankly is not going
to exist for more and more people
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
the Jordan Harbinger show is sponsoring
our podcasts and they're sponsoring us
because we're completely aligned they
have an episode literally talking about
the jobs of the future Jordan Harbinger
is kind of a badass and he brings on
these really fascinating people to talk
about self-improvement life improvement
yeah you're talking about an FBI hostage
negotiator teaching you how to get
people to like and trust you we all want
that Navy SEALs talking about developing
mental toughness and resilience who
doesn't want to have a little bitty seal
who badassness in their lives episode
with Neil deGrasse Tyson telling us how
the world works
the Jordan Harbinger show is one of
Apple's top podcasts for good reason
because it's the kind of thing that most
of us just want to find out more about
and they're so serious about you
internalizing each episode that there's
like a worksheet to make sure you do it
this podcast comes with homework can you
believe it but that means it's good in
this case so check out the Jordan
Harbinger show calm sly subscribe tell
them yangsun you actually there's no way
to do that but if you were we see that
yeah it's not like there's any credit
taking for this check out the Jordan
Harbinger show on Jordan Harbinger calm
sigh subscribe on Apple Spotify wherever
you get your podcasts
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the things that you table on the
trail and always scared me is that you
said people would say and you a love
your idea but you're ahead of your time
right or not yet and you would say if we
go too early what's the downside
like people get a little extra cash we
alleviate human suffering we start to
pilot work out the kinks if we go too
late you can't always put the genie back
in the bottle
because the jobs are gone other systems
are collapsing around you in addition to
the financial strain are we there are we
is that why you're reconsidering like
where is a genie out of the bottle
already
the genie right now is making its way up
through that narrow part of the lamp you
know what I mean the genie out of the
bottle that that I was imagining was
essentially the disintegration of
society riots food riots just complete
disregard for promises that are being
made institutions where people are just
like hanging like you know I just got to
get mines gonna take care of it
and after trust of roads to that degree
it's hard to restore trust like it's
much easier to undercut something than
it is to build something and the surest
example of this for anyone who's a
parent listening to this it's like you
know what goes into parenting your child
you know you know it goes in a parent of
your child over like days weeks months
years and the rest of it I mean it's and
I'm not to compare the two though I do
compare them sometimes but the same is
true of like building business building
a restaurant building like there's so
much work that goes into it and it's
much easier to firebomb the restaurant
than it is to build the restaurant you
know what I mean it's much harder to try
and say nothing's working than to make
something work and so there's been a
constant struggle or back-and-forth
where you know we we believe what our
leaders tell us we believe that you know
these institutions have our interests at
heart and one of the things
scared me the most was that there was a
very very clear trend in institutional
mistrust where the confidence we have in
our schools our hospitals our Congress
our media like all it essentially record
lows and it's very very hard to get
things done if no one has any trust so
the genie getting out of the bottle to
me was just a complete demolition of
public trusts and it's very very hard to
rebuild like it's not like oh you go too
late it's like all right now we're gonna
give people money then everyone's
hunky-dory again I mean like it's much
more than the money
it's like functionality you know it's
like like if I go to someone who's like
a drug addict on the street like you
know something homeless for months and I
just like start throwing money on top of
them like that doesn't necessarily solve
their problem
yet like in an ideal world you'd get to
them well before they reached that state
of dysfunction and a lot of those people
were in a position at one point where if
you've got a thousand bucks into their
hands they might not be on the street
you know like that that actually could
be theirs one of the most interesting
things I one of the great things about
running for president is I got to talk
to people are trying to solve these
problems everywhere and when I talked to
someone who is trying to work on
homelessness they said you know the
surest way to like combat homelessness
is to get people rent money when they're
about to become homeless like you know
how do things all as this is get someone
I rent money when they're about to be
evicted it seems so obvious but if you
wait too long and you go to them six
months after they're been homeless for a
while you know it's much much harder to
get them into that position because at
that point even if you gave them that
same amount of rent money they might not
be able to pass whatever check that the
landlord has they might not have the
furniture they might not have any kind
of like you know like credit to be able
to pay their utilities like whatever it
happens to be you know it's like in some
so many ways it's much cheaper and more
efficient to keep things functional than
it is to try and make something dis
no functional again so the tone on
universal basic income has shifted I
think in a good way
probably because of the level of
dysfunction happening right now
I think people are started coming around
but my question so like for me
personally it was crazy I literally on
vacation and seeing the president
knighted States and his his inner circle
talking about direct cash payments we
faced a lot of backlash while we were
running right because it's saying you
guys socialism you guys this you guys
that and now you see less of that andrew
is that because we're in desperate times
and people are looking like this seems
like the only solution that can work or
why like the Pope just came out for ubi
like what in your opinion why is it tone
coming around how is it coming around is
because of desperation they think you're
a genius like what what's your attitude
towards everybody else finally warming
up to this well certainly it's terrible
that we're in these circumstances but
it's common sense that if you're gonna
send home tens of millions of people
you're gonna need to send the money if
they're gonna be able to feed their
families pay their rent think about the
future not freak out not go outside and
you know just take something you know
you're gonna need to send them money and
I'm thrilled that we spent the last
number of months and years mainstreaming
an idea that became vital in the time of
crisis no I think people are seizing on
it now certainly because the crisis
makes it crystal clear to anyone with
any rationality at all that the best
thing you can do is put money straight
into people's hands right now in this
time it's the most effective thing and
to the extent that our campaign helped
speed up that realization I'm really
grateful to everyone who supported the
campaign throughout we used to joke when
things went our way we'd be like
campaign a destiny but now it's not
really a joke I mean I felt I felt
called to do it I know you
the timing seems you know in some ways
perfect because if a little later I
don't know a few B I had been on the
table in the war room you know well some
people know online are always telling me
on suspend on suspend I think that
starting to fade now that we're at this
point so you know you talk about the in
hair like perfect timing people like oh
wow like only the stated then you'd be
like frontrunner and whatnot I mean I
don't think that's the way it works I
mean but but I you know I certainly
think that you and I were called to do
what we did and that there been a lot of
people obviously that we're telling me
that I was right after the fact now that
we're all in this position right I do
think well in the early days I used to
say to friends or people criticized I do
you call them whatever you want to call
Andrew but you can't call them wrong
and sadly were right faster than we
probably want that anyone wanna be but I
do think directionally as a country if
it takes something like this to get us
there hopefully we can you know there's
one reason we have this podcast Andrew
is to talk about what needs to be talked
about you know um so I will hears that
I'd love to ask you Andrew as we as we
do this is okay we just what by Todd's
podcast comes out Americans are gonna
just start getting their first stimulus
check and sadly maybe I'm gonna get them
too late but let's say they pay their
first bill with the check hopefully the
government gets this Care Act and these
small business loans out there and they
start distributing money but this isn't
gonna be like I don't think you think
this is a band-aid solution like the
right you think this is a band-aid
solution this isn't a long-term fix my
question I think I think most listeners
want knows where do you think we go from
here not just on universal basic income
I'll do I think that's a big piece of
this but what what happens next society
there's long term effects here where do
you see the world going Post Cove in
nineteen a lot of it depends upon what
you're talking about when you say
kovat 19 and what this timeframe looks
like no like so I'm a positive guy and
so one of the things you try and look at
is like okay this is a terrible pandemic
it's killed tens of thousands of people
it's caused the loss of millions of
evaporation of millions of jobs
trillions of dollars worth of economic
harm so let's look for like the good
thing that's going to come out of it or
that's gonna come after it and I think
that's essentially [ __ ] is like this
this [ __ ] is terrible and you know
trying to look for the silver lining in
like this like historic shitstorm is
generally stupid like if you look at the
scale of the harm and the the loss of
opportunity and loss of life loss of
mental health loss of many relationships
it's heartbreaking man I mean I wake up
every day and it's just like I feel this
since I have to do something because I
just see how clear like see very clearly
how this traumatic and devastating this
is going to be for a generation so then
you ask okay like what the heck comes
out of it or what comes after so here's
here's how I see this stuff playing out
so we're all trapped inside right now
and the government at some point is
going to say some of us should go back
outside and right now it's essential
workers eventually it will be people who
have clear evidence of being immune to
kovat 19 primarily because they have the
antibodies they had it and were
asymptomatic or they had it and
recovered so those people will be good
to go a little bit sooner and more
quickly than others there are going to
be some people in some environments that
are good to go more quickly than others
there's some more industries that are
going to be identified as important I
believe the
there was one person who suggested you
know what we can get back to
construction and that might seem a
little strange but then his argument was
well a lot of that stuff is happening
outside you're not in each other's faces
if everyone has masks there's not gonna
be like crazy communities pregnant hair
right yeah like you know it's not like
and you know it's a it's a sort of thing
where you might be able to I actually do
some work there there are certain other
environments that you might reopen so
there's gonna be this phased in
reopening over time in certain
industries certain pockets certain
geographies that have just been spared
the ravages of kovat 19 to a higher
degree and then we're going to see fits
and starts of this kind of revival it's
not gonna be enough to you know get the
economy back to any kind of like health
or functionality but it'll be a little
better and that like there'll be more
people doing work in various settings
and a lot of it's going to just be fits
and starts certainly for a lot of this
year 2020 in the best-case scenario the
virus clears and we're actually able to
become more operational this year the
thing that most health experts are very
concerned about is a resurgence in the
fall
so apparently warm weather does slow the
spread somewhat and so the odds of there
being like an improvement in the summer
pretty significant and so we're gonna
start feeling better come Memorial Day
June like it's gonna feel a little bit
like we're getting back in the swing of
things I believe but then there's a
significant chance that it comes back in
a wave come to fall that is what
happened with Spanish flu like that like
the the fall wave was the most lethal in
that particular case now this is not a
flu in the same way but apparently some
of the trends are reflective and so a
lot of it hinges on when the heck do you
get the vaccine
and then after you get the vaccine when
does the vaccine get distributed to us
and it's not easy to distribute a new
vaccine to tens hundreds of millions of
people and the time frame you have on
the vaccine is let's call it 12 to 18
months would be her Herculean scientific
and industrial accomplishment so that's
where we are right now is that you
imagine that there is like a pre vaccine
in a post vaccine period the previous
team period could be significant and
measured in months or more and then that
transitional period is going to be very
very uneven so that's the path ahead for
us in my view and then what happens
after that as a response is dependent
largely upon who controls the government
and I have a very clear vision on what I
would do if I were in charge of
government entirely to try and help us
recover from this time I believe we need
a Marshall Plan scale rebuilding of this
country from the roots up and certainly
a universal basic income would be a very
big part of that trying to advance our
ability to address climate change would
be a big part of that measuring our
economy around our own well-being so
you'd have a massive investment in
mental health resources and universal
health care would be an enormous part of
that I mean the fact that we don't have
accessible healthcare has clearly made
this crisis worse because there are many
many Americans who were scared to even
interact with the healthcare system
because they didn't have the money they
thought to pay for things and we all
knew that Trump was bullshitting when he
was like if you need a test you can get
it like test for everyone was like no no
that's not true
it's like it showed up to my local
doctor Hospital I you know they would
just be like no test for you unless you
have clear symptoms or there's something
else going on here I mean I read this
heartbreaking story about this guy who
had this cancer
surgery pushed back because and he's you
know he could like die of cancer but it
got pushed back because he shows up the
hospital they're like hey can't have
surgery without a coronavirus test and
we don't have the tests so go get at
someplace else and then he went to a
doctor who had the tests and the doctor
was like I am NOT allowed to give you
the test unless you have coronavirus
symptoms and he's like oh I don't have
symptoms I'm trying to have surgery and
he's like can't help you so then they
had to to delay his surgery and then he
was like hey could the corona virus
could kill me even though I never got
the corona virus so so there they're
clearly massive problems that existed
with our access to healthcare that
universal healthcare would not have
alleviated all of them but it certainly
would have gone a great distance so
these are some of the big things I know
I would do if I were in charge of our
government and I would spare no expense
on national rebuild I would try to even
make it a global effort because climate
change is not something that we can
resolve alone I mean we're a relatively
low proportion of global emissions I
know where we're outweighed by the rest
of the world so I have a very clear
vision of what I would want to do and
I'm actually going to be delving into
that vision more and more because I
think it's really important to have that
vision I'm considering calling it the
great rebuild and that's where our
energy should go but the fact is you
need to have control of government to be
able to enact the great rebuild and the
big variable is what does the election
look like in November do we win by we I
mean like the non-trump
like do we win or does Trump win and I
mean that's a massive variable you know
I mean that there are actually in a
couple of ways like two huge hurdles
number one is we have to defeat Trump
and that is not going to be easy and I
think he just reported over 200 million
dollars or the Republicans reported 200
million dollars plus and fundraising in
q1
so they're going to have a lot of
resources that make their case plus he's
the sitting president so he's got the
bully pulpit he can use every day as
we're seeing with these briefings so
there's a good chance he wins even
though I think it's ridiculous that he
didn't have a chance given that his
incompetence and dishonesty has helped
lead us into this crisis that you know
that we lost two months that we could
have spent identifying infected people
and then contact tracing and trying to
contain the spread before I got to
community spread which is what sent us
all home but there's a real chance he
wins and then so let's say we defeat
Donald Trump that's major variable
number one and then major variable
number two is what does that government
look like are we united are we divided
our Democrats United are Democrats
divided is there a vision that people
can get behind our leader is sensitive
enough to the damage that has been done
to our people in our communities that
they realize that this is the time to
enact a great rebuild like this national
rebuilding project or do they just get
trapped in you know their usual partisan
battles while the the damage continues
to destroy lives you know in ways big
and small so those are the two big
variables I mean if you ask me like what
comes next you know that those are the
things I pay attention to and this is
something that I know many people who
follow me might not want to hear but the
government is going to be the center of
the universe in many respects for a
while to come because it's going to have
an outsized role in the economy and our
recovery and what the world looks like
going forward that's not a that's not an
appealing message to many people I know
but it's going to be our reality for for
quite some time
[Music]
[Applause]
right now today huge tech companies in
America that are paying next to nothing
in taxes are sucking up our data every
single day they are taking your web
history your email metadata your video
searches and they create a detailed
profile on you and then they cut it up
into little pieces and then sell it
resell it and we're none the wiser we
don't get a dime they're not just
selling their products anymore they're
selling us they're selling our data we
have become this product in this matrix
like a system where they're just taking
our info and making money off of it so
what can we do about it well we're
working on a few things to help but one
thing you can do is you can use Express
VPN every time you go online now what
the heck is expressed VPN VPN stands for
virtual private network and if you think
about all the websites you visit every
single day using your public IP address
they can match up your activity to your
IP address and that's how they know what
you're doing so if you want to be more
anonymous online and make it so that
you're more protected and they don't
know everything you're doing then you
can sign up on expressvpn it's pretty
easy to use I downloaded this it took me
30 seconds it was the easiest thing in
the world my internet runs just as fast
Salif an I've always been a fan of VPNs
our entire staff was very big on them
during the campaign because of data
privacy concerned so if this sounds like
something you'd be into visit expressvpn
dot-com / yang to get three months for
free on a one-year package that's exp
our e SS VPN dot-com / yang
that's expressvpn dot-com / yang you'll
be a little bit safe for a little bit
more secure a little bit more anonymous
and the tech companies will be left a
little bit poorer as a result not that
I'm out up to impoverish tech companies
but you know what I mean
[Music]
one of the things I want to do with this
podcast I know you do too is not have
people come here to be uplifted and
pander to I feel like they want to
listen to this for real information
um and the truth even if it's hard to
hear let me ask you this I think it's
actually kind of fun um president yang
oval office day one you find out Kona
virus is a thing it exists you've talked
with us forth me but I'd love you to
share first moves your thoughts and then
what do you start communicating to the
people as information comes in so do you
mean back in January when you get
reports that this is yeah let's say like
to start right I think how are you how
would you approach getting the
information and what how would you
approach what to communicate in action
steps to take you know it's tough
because a lot of the information out of
China you could not trust me know one
thing that other countries did that was
awesome I don't know if we could have
done this is they just sent people there
they said people of Wuhan be like hey go
find out what the hell's going on over
there
so what so some of the countries that
really got on top of this like Taiwan
and South Korea had people on the ground
who saw that [ __ ] and went back to
Taiwan South Korea I was like hey fYI
don't believe anything they're saying
this thing is a buzz saw and we need to
go bananas in terms of like tamping down
travel tracking anyone who comes back
testing the crap out of everyone who
might even have had contact and and so
that that's the ideal first move is you
see this is going on and then you see
the Chinese government is dissembling or
trying to pull the wool over people's
eyes and be like you know what like the
you know you imagine if you've watched
World War Z it's like a brad pitt type
person or character that you just like
said that said I'd be like yo see what
is going on right and we're back to us
so so that would be you know the one of
the first things you do
second thing is you talk to your your
doctor faustus of the world near
medical professionals and you say okay
what are the steps that we can take to
prepare for this if it does come mean
pretty much you look at it and you have
like five things at once like number one
you're trying to get information about
what the heck is going on over there so
you can be prepared number two is you
coordinate with international partners
so you can information share and what
what's going on in other parts of the
world this is one reason I'm so angry
that we're so asleep at the switch cuz
like [ __ ] went crazy in like half a
dozen countries and we still acted like
nothing was happening right it was nuts
you know number three you do everything
you can limit that can the the infection
rate of people who are coming into the
states so that is cut off travel from
affected areas that is put people
through screenings if they're coming
from someplace that might be affected
that is self quarantine measures where
you say look you're coming back from
someplace you're an American citizen so
we're not gonna like not let you come
back but guess what you're gonna have to
like hang out in your home for two weeks
we're gonna check up on you and we're
going to monitor every person that you
came into contact with just in case you
might have come home with an extra bug
and then number five you assume that
none of that's going to work and you
just start trying to build the the
infrastructure around testing
ventilators hospital beds PPE and
everything else just assuming that you
know it's very hard to completely
eliminate contagion from like a you like
getting to a country the size of the
United States of America so you'd
ideally do all these things at once in
terms of the what you communicate to the
American people you get up there and say
hey fYI there's this virus that is
wreaking havoc on other parts of the
world you do not need to worry about it
just yet in the sense that we like seem
to be safe and secure but if you have
been to one of these places you need to
take this very seriously
and self-quarantine we're gonna screen
you if for some reason we don't know who
you are contact this we all have to be
very vigilant to take this very
seriously to try and minimize disruption
and maximize our people's health and
safety and just come out with it very
early and say look if we stay on top of
this we can escape the fate that has
befallen some of the other countries if
you look at the countries I really had a
great time of it they just tested the
heck out of everyone merly
and they had some built up experience
from SARS so you know it's not quite
apples to apples like expecting us to be
on the bus on the ball as on these
places but South Korea literally had
like drive-through testing
pretty quickly like like anyone who
wanted a test you know could could go
get them and you'd get results pretty
quick too
so like it's unfathomable to me that
that other countries had that capacity
and we still don't you know it's like if
we had the right relationship so gonna
be like what's that like you have this
set of tests all right
like let's see if we can replicate we
can make the proper investments you know
we can import we can do whatever it
takes so that you know okay if you can
imagine a world where like when someone
was landing from an affected area then
like there was like someone waiting in
there with a test for them yeah you know
like I mean like that that's like the
dream but that's something that other
countries actually managed to deliver on
to a significant measure what role we at
on the campaign we and one thing about
this Tuesday I want to say it's like we
were in Iowa when the first reports of
this [ __ ] were coming out like I
remember seeing the reports and like I
think I tweeted in late January I was
like this coronavirus is very serious
because like I saw like this thing just
seems like like it's it's crippling you
know like anyway so like let you know I
dearly wish that I had been president
frankly when this stuff was going on
because I genuinely think that we might
all be outdoors right now and everyone
would think that's like
it's you know like oh that like they
were they sure were alarmist about this
thing because it's funny like America
would never known what we would have
missed if we would have missed it but
now that were trapped in our homes were
like ah like you know if someone could
have done something to prevent and
imagine all the harm that could have
been prevented when we are the campaign
we you and I both learned a lot about
our media and the incentives they have I
think we had our own projections and
then we learned a lot more about them as
we went what what role the media play in
in the information game here and I asked
that knowing like I'm trying to figure
out who I can trust you've got the
president saying one thing CDC saying
another and then every network given
their own spin or take on it how do you
how have you thought about that and if
you're a president well I mean I know
you got a lot of ideas about the media
but what would what would you do given
that the hand you're dealt with our
current media I mean these journalists
are at a real disadvantage I mean you
know I think having really trusted
credible scientific Authority that
everyone's listening to is the best way
to go you know if you're an effective
president you're listening to those self
same people and then in many ways you're
just delivering those talking points to
the American people because the facts of
the facts the science of the science and
you know you shouldn't have people
having mixed messages to that extent and
then if you're the press and you see
this you're like well the scientists and
doctors and public health officials say
this the president is saying something
that's essentially the same and so then
we just report that you know and and
that would be the ideal situation and
then you'd have a much higher degree of
consensus I think sure sure you'd have
some people that are like oh this is
like you know this is nuts this is wrong
but I think that would be a really minor
or a small group of people if you had a
very consistent message right
thank you see some governor's doing that
really well or they're consistent their
message in their state sir shutting down
appropriately or acting appropriately
you know this is something I was one of
like you know I learned so much running
in this campaign but one of the things I
figured out that I actually found very
frustrating initially so I'm like an
operator and entrepreneur like you know
done a few things and I joked all the
time about the fact that running for
president was like an exercise in awful
awful leadership because if you had a
CEO who all they did was like run after
TV cameras all the time and like try and
get on the air with their point of view
their company is probably crumbling
behind them you know it's like if any
CEOs like just like that much of a
publicity hound one they're probably not
a really great person and to their
organizations probably not performing
well either and so I would joke all the
time that like you know it's like this
this process is like the opposite of
what good leadership looks like and
there's something about politics to
where you see it on the governance to
it's like like you have the projecting
of a particular message that's
consistent a particular emotional tenor
like okay this person has their [ __ ]
together I trust them I believe them I
feel better about our situation there's
that entire thing and that's crucially
important in many ways that that's a lot
of what we're asking for our politicians
from right now but then there is all of
the executive operations of trying to
make things work right you know in a way
that like the best government would be
of people who try to prevent the need to
ever have to project calm because they
like kept the problem from happening
[Laughter]
like that there's this thing I found
frustrating
I still do someone is you have like the
the the communication and the projection
and the conveying of certain feelings
and messages and then you have the
actual
get [ __ ] done operations work and so
much of our politics seems based around
the first one it's like this person
makes me feel good this person does not
make me feel good and most politicians
at this point I've just shrugged and
said okay like that's the realm we're
going to do battle on like you know you
have your symbols and words and feelings
I have my symbols and words and feelings
and then the consultant will tell me you
know what word really works well this
one and then you're like I'll use that
word you know and that'll really send a
message to this subgroup and the rest of
it and and it just seems and it is just
such [ __ ] and like it and what's
funny is that like I don't think I ever
ended up subscribing that stuff because
like you know no consult never said say
this word or any of that jazz to me or
if they did like you know you kept it
from happening where I ignored it or
whatever
um well but what's funny is like like
like I just did my like you know say
what comes naturally or just like
express what I believe or think and then
that became its own set of like words
and symbols in its own way so that there
was like a real education but there was
a big part of me that thinks like man
like you know like ideally we wouldn't
have this world of like competing press
conferences you know I mean like there's
just like an objective reality we settle
on how to improve it as fast as possible
and you know that doesn't strike me as
particularly political it was one of the
things we struggled with on the campaign
andrew is that you we had I mean you
have we have our consults like everybody
does we have experts and advisors that
say though just to be clear we didn't
have [ __ ] for consultants for a long
time until we started doing well and
then the consultants came out and then
even then we blew them off most of the
time and just kept him in a box and said
just leave us alone
and every once in a while will like need
you to do something that's done that
shut the hell up
yeah yes and I was a driver of that in
many ways but I will say there was an
element of like part of we couldn't just
this is the hardest part like you had
the right ideas and you're just like I
don't care about how we just need to
solve them and one of the hardest
realizations for I think both of us like
in order for that to gain more traction
and get more popular we have to make you
more popular right you had to you had to
use your words and symbols and
engagements and debate sound bites and
all these things that and not even any
people's fault in some ways just stuff
that we could do to cut through the
noise or mainstream and I frankly I
thought that sucked like it like the raw
yang was always like the the most pure
to me
but I did understand it there's one
things we had to like argue about on the
campaign trail you know or just find
that balance well one of the things that
really hit me the hardest was that
universal basic income started out with
an approval rating in Iowa of like 25
percent according to our polls and then
we got it all the way up to 66 percent
it's like a 41% increase so like
two-thirds of Iowans were like yeah is a
good idea and then you ask them why do
you think it's a good idea and it's not
any of the arguments that we made like
the the reason why they thought it was a
good idea is that they started to like
Andrew yang and say it's like oh this
guy seems smart and well intended and he
says it's a good idea so now I think
it's a good idea like and like that was
why they started to like it yeah like it
wasn't like oh this would help me oh it
would like improve mental health they
would create jobs like none of the stuff
that we said actually moved the needle
like the fact that eventually it became
comfortable - Andrew yeah they like me
they they'd like me enough to like you
know frankly like saw me and I was
president at least I mean like only 5% I
mean I mean 5% thank you the 5% I'm
feeling if we ran that and we ran that
back now would probably be a lot higher
but but but like that that set of polls
demonstrated to me what I knew and then
I have to relearn over and over again
which is that people don't subscribe to
ideas people subscribe to other people
mm-hmm that you that in order for an
idea to take off the idea needs to have
a person that is carrying it around or
like is wrapped up in it or that you
associate with it and without that
Association the person the idea then the
idea doesn't move past a certain point
and it took me a long time to figure
that out even though I figured it out
before like the same thing happened to
me when I started a non-profit where
someone said to me it's like hey for the
nonprofit to do well like you have to
become well-known respected admired
which arguably never happened but
whatever so but like he was like you
know these two things are tied together
like and you know I like resisted it
then too because I was like well the
idea of the nonprofit should stand on
its own but then it turns out that the
two things were linked and the same
thing was true in our campaign where
there's universal basic income which I
think objectively is an awesome idea and
like anyone looking at it should just be
like yeah we should do that but it takes
humans to persuade other humans that
ideas are worth exploring and that that
core right there was the hardest for you
and I and the team to like get used to
you know you and you just generally like
going from being able to do whatever you
want at a time to walking down the
street and people asking for selfies the
entire way down New York City right and
because it had to be it had to be you
had to be a person and what started as
this campaign idea of ideas ended up
having be a campaign of ideas through
Andrew yang which is a different plate
of ideas in people yeah well and this is
one thing that happened with us with so
this is Zack story so I'm not a
particularly
vane or
person I suppose and then Zack would
just sort of shrugged me like that's
cool for a while and then at some point
in the campaign Zack was like hey we're
gonna get your haircut okay we're gonna
give you like it consisted look like hey
you know get you a math pin instead of
like the campaign button or whatever was
where was I started trying to identify
variables to clean me up and
professionalize me that left on my own I
might never have actually recognized or
done now like I'm not an idiot where
it's like when it's suggested to me I'm
like well maybe that's a good idea
but but like it's so that those are some
of the adaptations we made where you
start and we started out and what's
funny is like I compared myself to
Bernie I was like Bernie looks like the
freakin you know scientist and back to
the future like no one gives a [ __ ] like
you know like like why would anyone give
a [ __ ] about like you know my hair like
who cares but then like there was a
point where we said it's like well maybe
some people do care it's like maybe
people don't we're new to so Bernie Ben
ascent for years and had a national run
in 2016 if the first oddly like your
first 30-second impression of you on TV
and they don't like your hair they don't
like your shirt or whatever it's it
would way it would it would I mean wait
till we run again man I picked out a
stylist and everything we're going
all-in I'll make you a G Oh No before
you know it I mean the biggest the
biggest add up to I mean there were some
of the adaptations for me running for
president but the biggest one was
wearing so much [ __ ] makeup like I
would go I mean not to say like I would
just put on independently but if I the
TV appearance they would just like put
makeup on and then our disability or at
least and we keep this on keep it on
which was hilarious well I'd keep it on
half the time because I had another TV
today so I'm just like am I really gonna
remove the makeup and then like get it
on again like plus between the two TV
appearances I probably had like you know
half of like social photos social media
things so I'd just be like I made sense
it was but but it was but it was odd
because like you know like you
you're not used to that stuff and like
everyday life it was it's like for me
like knowing you're an operator you're
an entrepreneur you're builder you're
the person that leads the meetings like
that's who you've always been to me
right before I boy I ran by the end man
like you didn't get to breathe up five
people telling you where to do it you
know and that was wild and you were like
you took a while by the end of it you're
like I just tell me to go time ago yep
what am I doing here yep got it which is
I was joking that that like my job was
just to be grenade and then be like tell
me tell me where to blow up like roll me
into the room yeah wasn't even the room
it's like roll me into the auditorium
rolled me into the TV studio roll me at
the Y you could just like hey just have
a compelling 50 man stump speech that
people like you you can see how a
politician gets cut that way it makes
sense I understand what politicians go
through now I understand why politicians
are so guarded and scripted because like
you go off-script for a minute and then
people freaking you know like jump on
you for it and I'm sure most every major
politician had that experience early on
it was like and everything by five
people before I do it yeah I think I saw
a story about how like Hillary Clinton
when she was tweeting I think they were
like you know four or five people I
would check every tweet you know
whatever before it went and then Donald
Trump it's obviously zero so I joke that
the right number is somewhere between
zero and five we know for the record
there's zero in my Twitter too but I'm a
very different man than Donald Trump I
will say it does cause the staff like
anxiety for sure in this sense that you
know Twitter doesn't matter it only
matters in the extremes right like give
you say something really offensive you
know like a racial slur or something
then it matters but the other end left
you like does that what kind of what
kind of like crazy person would be like
putting racial slurs and right agree
sorry so there's but there
certain end of like the the staff was
like what is Andrew tweeting about about
oh no you want to ask him my god
yeah well well sometimes sometimes I
would be guilty of tweeting without
context where I tweet something and it
would be like you composing as to what
that was based upon yeah you know the
fact is half the time I was in some
freaking you know SUV or bus in I were
in New Hampshire and like I'd be
tweeting about something like totally
innocuous oh yeah or you would tweet
about a policy and like that policy team
didn't know anything about it like
you're like you know someone's talking
about this awesome idea I think it's
brilliant we should do it and you were
right the ball it seems like maybe like
whatever I like I you know as we as you
know the campaign manager I thought it
was a good thing to let you be you and
fight the battles of appropriately it
was a lot of our club strategy right
we'd be like Andrew what do you think
about this current event and you'd give
us your thoughts and we would say Yes No
maybe so and then say go forth with that
right
well I remember some of the policies
that you're talking about like one was a
you know I think we should legalize
online poker yeah or legalizing
psychedelic mushrooms or decriminalized
opiates for personal use I mean all of
those things were from interactions with
people where like a military vet would
tell me it's like hey the only thing
that works my PTSD is psychedelic
mushrooms and I was like wow that's a
pretty good argument for a minimum of
vets being able to have psychedelic
mushrooms because you know if it's
effective and you've tried everything
else he's like oh yeah I have I believed
him too I mean he'd been through you
know a lot so yeah so yeah I'd learned
continuously and you're like hopefully
they're most the time like you know I'd
try and well actually there are
definitely times I didn't tell anyone I
was going to tweet something we could do
a whole I mean we probably will do a
whole episode like campaign recaps and
what we learned and things like that I
won I think what this helped us andrew
is like one we had you and - we were
building on the fly so we got to like I
have like a lot of thought and I think a
lot of team would have a lot of thoughts
on how to structure a presidential
campaign in the 21st century like I
think
a lot of things at a traditional
campaign just doesn't need or needs less
of and you know so we had that you know
we had you know a ton of policies up the
off your cup so having a deep policy
team wasn't always you know use the
fullest extent even though you have some
of the brightest minds on that team
things like that calms you were and I
spend a lot of time on comms we need
like a full end common no wait really
talented team so stuff like that I think
your you structure the team around the
candidate I suppose the other way around
I think yeah definitely not structuring
the candidate around the team that's
right my because this candidate can't
control you know it's like we labored in
anonymity for a good year you know yeah
and then the consultants came in and be
like do this do that and really I [ __ ]
you remember you called
you called us member those guys that me
not Oliver bad you know but you see how
politics get so screwed up quickly you
know like that there there are all these
institutional forces that come into it
you know it starts out as something
deeply personal becomes deeply
institutionalized very very quickly and
you know I'm really proud of the fact
that I think we stayed true to ourselves
the whole time and even as we started
doing better and better we stuck to what
got us there I think almost what we did
yeah what's crazy but the biggest thing
is we had like a clear vision clear set
of ideas yes you know why it's like
those like those ideas now have more and
more power and currency because now we
see very clearly that they were
necessary oh my gosh that was thing by
this morning man's like can you imagine
what solutions would be throwing on the
table if you hadn't run you know I I
don't know man I shudder to think well
certainly even now it's like if you look
at it the vast majority of the money in
the Cara's Act the stimulus package
go to us you know so like you can you
can imagine an even lower proportion
going to human beings which would have
been an utter disaster as it is I think
we can dial up the level of money that's
coming straight to people I think we're
gonna get another check coming our way
pretty quickly because this 1200 is not
going to work for very very long if your
outlook is correct yeah we're going to
do something and I hope they continue to
turn to your PlayBook you know yeah
we're gonna keep on building out the
PlayBook man that's one of the things
I'm excited about doing is is
establishing a vision for the great
rebuild and just giving people more and
more tools like letting people know it's
like look ubi is vital and necessary and
we should do it we should do it very big
and consistent but then we have to do
this too we have to make progress on
health care we need to make progress on
climate change need to make progress on
infrastructure and we need to measure
economy differently we need a massive
Mental Health Initiative you know like
these are things that we need we need to
start using technology in our favor we
need to start having intelligent
moderation of some of the downsides that
come with technology because to the
extent that there are downsides with the
use of technology we're about to see
them all turned up to 11 because we're
all trapped inside so that there is some
very very big issues on the horizon that
we need to try and build the playbook
for as quickly as possible and that's
one of the things I'm excited about
doing right now is building that
playbook if you're excited about finding
out that playbook is you know it's like
if you listen to these conversations
we're gonna be talking to people who
help us build the PlayBook and it's it's
going to be ongoing but I'm excited for
it you know we need it all right ladies
and gentlemen that's our first episode
of Yang speaks it's gonna be fascinating
we'll have fun conversations sometimes
be serious sometimes I've experts on
sometimes up celebs sometimes be
strangers randos or nobody just Andrew
either way the goals talk about the
future and outline a playbook that we as
a country in society desperately need to
follow to improve all of our lives and
even the tough times I'm some fun and
frankly yang is low-key hilarious so I
hope you guys get a good laugh to tune
in next Monday
yang gang is out
[Music]